In terms of values, humility,
being down to earth,
thinking critically and objectively about strength and weaknesses,
meaning that if one of my children,
which of course they're gonna have a weakness,
just like I myself have 100 or 1,000 weaknesses,
whenever our children have weaknesses or flaws in their character
or being unfair, let's say they're treating their siblings unjustly,
I'm gonna do my best as a parent
to invest a lot of time in sitting down with my children and saying,
hey, this is what happened.
You need to think logically,
need to think objectively and lyrically about yourself,
because we are not always right.
Maybe you were right, maybe your brother,
maybe your sister was right.
Find out how you're right and find out how you're wrong.
And then think about how your brother was right and how he was wrong
and then have a logical conversation about that.